okay so we're picking up with an x-men
one shot which is technically issue
number 20 and it's actually further
ahead from the last place we were we
basically stopped with the end of x of
sorts uh if you guys want me to
cover all the stuff between x of swords
and now we can't i don't see any reason
not to and the other question i have is
do you guys care about anything that's
not x-men related because if you don't
i'll just hold off on that stuff some of
that stuff's cool and i'll cover it
anyway but let me know what you guys
think uh having said that if you guys
remember there was a story that we did
previously
when mystique was sent on a mission and
then she returned and when she returned
she was gravely injured but we didn't
really know exactly what was going on
this basically fills in a lot of those
gaps right it's the nature of hickman
we're kind of jumping back to a degree
and so one of the things that we've seen
previously is that irene adler who's
actually
really was a topic of discussion on
twitter where people were asking if
mystique had a romantic relationship
with irene adler and the answer is yes
uh chris claremont never really hit it
on the nose he was never like and
they're together and they're sleeping
together you know it wasn't really
anything like that
but by all stands as a measurement you
could basically look at the context of
the situation and know that they were a
couple they referred to each other as
lovers pretty consistently and so
because of that um one of the things
that's gone on here is irene adler
is as a lot of you guys know destiny but
destiny has not been resurrected
and the ongoing theme here the reason
why is because with charles xavier and
magneto running krakowa there's
something kind of
sinister going on with everything
they're doing more so than that the
entirety of krakowa hinges on
hope that's it that's all it hinges on
the idea that as long as the mutants are
there on that island their future is
basically guaranteed if i'm a betting
man
i would say that that professor x and
magneto are more or less using all the
mutants as cannon fodder but they see
them as a as almost like messianic
characters they don't really worship
them as gods but they're the people who
kind of came along with a plan that was
really formulated by maura mctaggart and
it was we can all sort of save ourselves
and live in a singular location
that kind of a thing right we can have a
home unto our own it's not like genocio
where like 16 million of us were
murdered but we'll be safe here
and so that's why a lot of the mutants
that existed out there ended up casting
aside their differences
former villains took up residence on
krakowa so long as they follow the rules
the big issue here is that with destiny
she can see the future if you guys
remember the old stories with like
destiny's diaries she can see the future
and so
if destiny's brought back and she knows
what's going to happen and presumably
even though we don't know it yet the
future is going to be laden with just
mutants dying all over the place because
krakow is going to prove to be a failure
that information would come out and
people would abandon krakowa right so
destiny just hasn't been brought back
now we're assuming that's the case
we don't know definitively if that's
true or not but it's one of these things
where mystique trusts destiny implicitly
and so one of the things that kind of
goes on is ultimately mystique travels
to meet with forge now forge is a
character that we've talked about before
and for a lot of you guys who are new
and who are unfamiliar with forge
imagine him as being the tony stark of
the mutant population the difference
between forge and tony stark is tony
stark is just legitimately intelligent
forge's intelligence is a result of his
mutant power and so if you took his
mutation away he'd be nowhere near as
capable as he is right now but with his
mutation he is in a lot of ways on par
with tony stark
the result of this is that mystique and
forge kind of had this discussion where
they're talking about sort of creating
tools right this idea
that when mystique says she needs forge
to work on something the response of
forge is well it depends on what it is
that you want and
in the right hands anything is a weapon
like i can create something like i can
use a stick and in the right hands a
stick is a weapon
and he kind of talks about the nature of
humanity and says that humanity for the
most part
always start out with the the logic of
we were starting with the good
intentions right we started with good
intentions and look at where we ended up
and he says it's always the same way
like the the combustible engine computer
processors
atomic energy genetic engineering that
it all ends up starting with quote
unquote the best
of intentions and then look where they
are they're using technology rooted in
combustible engines to create engines of
war they're using computer processors to
develop sentinels that are anti-mutant
atomic energy led to the nuclear age
like just the you know death tolls on a
massive scale genetic engineering led to
desires to remove
powers of not just mutants but
superpowered beings across the world
all equally it's one of these things
where humanity has always taken
the tools that they had that were used
with or at least developed with good
intentions and then weaponized them and
it's really kind of pointing the finger
at this idea that it's in the nature of
humanity to screw stuff up this is the
nature of humanity to do things that are
inherently bad right we're inherently
self-destructive and it's kind of an
interesting philosophy because one of
the things that i find so intriguing
about the way that
jonathan hickman writes mutants is that
there was never a definition more
accurate of the mutant population than
during days of future past when
sentinels came to the realization that
mutants are the next stage of human
evolution therefore
mutants are humans or simply just
modified humans with a modified gene but
at the same time they're almost pretty
much the exact same way right
mutants follow the same logic as humans
it's not as though developing an x gene
suddenly leads to you understanding and
developing a higher state of reasoning
right like you're still human at your
core
in terms of how you function how you
think emotions all that kind of good
stuff and so
it's it's really cool because mutants
almost seem to kind of see themselves
above the human population despite being
a part of the human population in terms
of how they think and feel there really
isn't a whole lot of difference there
that's that's what's so ironic is
because with this discussion going on
between the two of them is basically
revealed the job of
forge is to develop a weapon for
mystique to carry out a mission right to
essentially develop a bomb and all of
this
is rooted in orcis now what we end up
doing is kind of transitioning to
mystique when she travels to the house
of m which is basically the base of
operations where at least kind of like
the private citadel where the council
meets right where you have xavier you've
got magneto and we basically end up
finding out that what happened is forge
created a microscopic singularity
generator basically he created an
artificial black hole when the bomb goes
off an artificial black hole will
basically grow an artificial black hole
will come into existence and then blink
out almost in the blink of an eye but
because
artificial black holes and even black
holes in general have such a strong
gravitational pull
that's all they need and so the idea is
that when the bomb goes off in the orca
space station it'll quite literally
destroy the station itself it won't
really destroy anything else right it
won't destroy sentinel city where
they're developing
all the different sentinels that are
there or their system of orbital
platforms
but basically it'll kill the heart of
the orcis operation and after that
it's just cleanup duty and so because of
that the whole purpose of mystique is to
go there and pull this off and she's
supposed to be doing it on her own and
so what she ends up doing is actually
donning the disguise
of a member of advanced idea mechanics
operating within
orcus now a little bit of jumping back
here right because again this is the
nature of hickman we're going all the
way back to house and powers of x with a
lot of these references here so one of
the things if you guys recall from that
is that orcas was a multinational
organization
that basically had a lot of members from
different groups that were part of its
mission right so advanced idea mechanics
hydra just ordinary uh human scientists
all kinds of different things
but it existed for the singular purpose
of finding a way to destroy the mutant
population
on earth right it's really in a lot of
ways the biggest gambit of humanity
right the single
largest undertaking of humanity and
trying to eliminate mutants up to this
point it was just
laws that were being passed or the
mutant registration act or something
like that and in a lot of ways they
didn't really have much teeth
groups like friends of humanity for
those of you guys who remember the old
school stuff back in like the 80s and
90s
stuff like the right those kind of
organizations actually came closer to
destroying the mutant population even
guys like william striker they came
closer to destroying the mutant
population than the government ever did
but the governor was also bound by laws
you know the government couldn't just
arbitrarily create sentinels and then
send them indiscriminately across the
world killing mutants but cassandra nova
could
or like the friends of humanity could or
william striker could i mean sure they
were violating the law and doing it but
as long as they stayed under the radar
everything was fine with things like a
project wide awake it was a lot harder
to do
because there were a lot more moving
parts and a lot more organizations
involved and so kind of picking up at
the orcis forge
if you guys recall aelia she was married
to erasmus and erasmus was one of the
guys who died facing off against mutants
in house and powers of x
and while we haven't really seen what
she's been doing what we basically learn
here is that she's been working on
building
the perfect sentinel to essentially
plant her husband's consciousness in so
they can begin the the process of
developing
more advanced sentinels and then
ultimately destroying humanity and then
ultimately destroying the mutant
population
the way she's done this is wildly
intriguing because the philosophy behind
alien and even orcas as a whole
is when it comes to the sentinels that
exist out there they abide by
programming right whatever it is their
programming tells them to do
they will do and they can't deviate
beyond their programming right they're
very limited in terms of how they
function
but what if you could take a human being
and you could take their consciousness
you could basically synthesize it right
so all the memories you've experienced
in your life can be broken
down into basically binary code ones and
zeros and then put into a machine and so
your essence and what makes you who you
are
is is confined within this machine
itself but the machine itself
is virtually indestructible with a whole
host of abilities and that's what she's
done
she's taken her husband's consciousness
and she put it in a sentinel she
basically created nimrod and so this is
a huge
change from what we're used to with the
x-men mythos and we knew this was coming
because of what jonathan hickman has
done over the years
time he's been writing the x-men and
marvel comics originally nemrod was
created by other sentinels and that was
one of the big failings of nimrod
despite his capabilities and what he
could do
he was severely limited because he was
limited by the programming that was
given to him by other machines that were
limited by their own program
but unlike that this is a human being
humans have no limitations we're 100
complete imagination and so whatever we
can conceive
we can create and that's the big thing
about elia and about people like her is
because she's not bound by the the
concept of just we need to create a
machine that can kill mutants we'll make
it super advanced instead
it's things like taking the artificial
mind of a human being and putting it
inside of a machine
and so when erasmus wakes up he suddenly
starts to realize this is kind of weird
to me but at the same time starts to
pick up on the fact that he's got all
kinds of different abilities here now
this is the nature of nimrod and this is
why i call
nimrod the deadliest enemy of all
mutants because it's one thing when
you're facing off against somebody like
apocalypse apocalypse is very capable
and apocalypse is exceedingly powerful
but apocalypse's singular motivation is
not to just
eradicate the mutant population is to
test both mutants and humanity to get
rid of the weak and so because of that
we're not talking about just outright
elimination we're talking about
culling more or less with nimrod it's
kill everybody right every single mutant
just kill them all
now there is a little bit of difference
here because you've got erasmus inside
this system but nonetheless nimrod was
designed with a host of abilities that
made him the perfect machine to take out
mutants he could detect mutants pretty
much anywhere within his immediate
vicinity and figure out what their
weakness was and then use that against
them he could basically duplicate almost
any superhuman power that he saw he
could teleport he could shape-shift
nimrod could do it all
i mean the guy was just a swiss army
knife of just weapons right i mean just
he was literally a one-man band that's
why he was made the way he was was just
to be the most efficient mutant killer
that could possibly be found the kicker
to all this is that while
rasmus is limited to his physical form
he does have all these powers and
all the imagination to go along with it
and so in a moment he's actually sort of
hugging alia and really cherishing the
moment that he's back and the gifts that
she's given him and then just kind of
looks over and says that's a mutant
just like that mystique is caught and
it's just that's that's the craziness
of of nimrod right like under any normal
circumstance they never would have known
she was there she could have just snuck
through the whole
place and she could have planted the
bomb at her own leisure and then left
and called it a day but she's literally
standing in the presence of a being with
the power to sense mutants
anywhere in his immediate vicinity with
mystique's bluff being called she does
the only thing she can do she basically
runs and so she essentially in the
process
activates the bomb and this basically
sets off or begins a process of creating
this kind of singularity
in the middle of the forge the problem
with mystique's plan is she didn't fully
understand what she was going to be
going with one of the first abilities
that was given to nimrod or given to
erasmus in the body of nimrod by aelia
was to make sure he couldn't die and so
she gave him the power to duplicate
himself the issue with this is that it
takes time for the memory core to
develop and so once he immediately
duplicates himself into several versions
and then sends them out some of which go
after mystique the others actually
gather together to get rid of the bomb
that he's told by alia
if you detonate this bomb right if you
take this bomb out there and you die
with it all your clones basically die we
can
you know your main version here that's
with me right now will live but you'll
lose too many pieces of yourself right
for every version of yourself that dies
you lose more of yourself along the way
and in the end erasmus says
that's a price i'm willing to pay right
i love you i miss you but i understand
that keeping you alive
is the most important thing and so what
some of his versions do is they actually
disconnect the uh the part of the ship
with a bomb attached to it floating out
into space
and they all end up being destroyed
along with it right the station's secure
but the bomb is detonated and so when
she asks erasmus
are you there then like in turn he just
responds the way a robot would
right dr alia gregor i'm sorry to tell
you what it is that i'm about to tell
you but basically
her husband's gone this is probably the
single most important moment in jonathan
hickman's run
of x-men up to this point because for
house and powers of x
we didn't know how it was that we went
from the arrival of nimrod or the
creation of nimrod
to this moment right here where he kind
of became like a robot right the robot
that we all know
and the one that we all love to be
honest for us as x-men fans we just
simply knew he was there at some point
and so because that this is the origin
this is the new origin of nimrod
in in the x-men comics where basically
he was engineered to be a hybrid between
a human and a robot and lost his
humanity
almost immediately into being created
and so following that one of his clones
tracks down mystique and then basically
attacks her blaster
right back through the portal to kokoa
and then tells her tell your masters
that you failed tell your masters that
i'm that my system is online and it's
only a matter of time
before we come for them know that nimrod
the hunter is alive and well
and nimrod will see the end of you all
and so you get this kind of amazing
moment here where you pick up with omega
and you pick up with the leader of orcis
of course omega having been an omega
sentinel once upon a time
and was really the first attempt and and
really the one of the first and only
successful attempts to kind of make a
human sentinel hybrid
it worked out well but then things kind
of went away because the reality was
she had too much humanity in her but the
important thing here is that the leader
of orcas just kind of looks where
omega's just kind of like man like you
know they almost killed us
like we need to be on our guard the
leader of orcis is like no we don't
right this tells us
everything that we need to know right
and kind of starts laughing at this
whole thing and when she asks what's so
funny he says like we weren't hurt like
we were not badly hurt at all like with
the with the exception of losing erasmus
or the harassment persona of nimrod
we're not hurt like we're fun
ultimately they're afraid of us if they
weren't afraid of us they would not have
launched this mission and so it means
we're getting to them
right like it means our purpose is being
served with fear comes recklessness
and with recklessness comes mistakes
it's only a matter of time before we
catch them off guard
and we eradicate them all and so
following that because the resurrection
of destiny hinged on mystique being
successful in her mission when she gets
back
she basically has to tell xavier and
magneto that she failed that nimrod is
online and this is when things
really begin to start falling apart for
magneto and xavier and the reason for
this is because the question that
mystique asks is
what about irene and they kind of look
at her and say what about her this is
probably one of the worst mistakes they
could have made and the reason why is
because there are times when you really
just kind of have to appease
but the risk they take by bringing back
destiny is that she would make everybody
aware of the fact that the future is
going to fall apart that they're all
probably going to be used as cannon
fodder and ultimately execute and
they're all ultimately going to die and
so what you get is this kind of voice
over or at least this kind of memory
that was uh the statement i guess that
was told to mystique
by irene out of at a previous point in
time before she died and she said
at some point in time xavier and magneto
are going to create some kind of mutant
utopia a place that's going to be
sort of billed to you guys as hopeful
but ultimately they're selling you on a
false bill of goods
this place will seem to be hope for our
kind for the mutant population
when those days come when that mutant
utopia is created
and they come to you as saviors bring me
back and if they cannot do it or they
will not do it then
burn the place to the ground and so
what's effectively happened here
is that magneto and xavier have made an
enemy out of what could arguably be
considered one of the deadliest mutants
in existence
because how can you catch what you can't
see and that's the nature of mystique to
kind of
keep from being caught and it's kind of
a crazy thing and so essentially
it all looks like it's getting ready to
fall apart it all looks like it's
getting ready to end with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace